Why is France doing so badly?
But what's going on
even today ?
1 man was uh.
Shot dead in the middle of the night at the blanc-mesnil.
We don't have more information.
The criminal has seized the case.
Two police officers committed suicide.
Still today,
this is the twenty-first suicide since the
beginning of the year.
1 teacher was killed this Friday,
so on.
Gambetta High School,
so, where uh.
The teacher was killed was evacuated
because there was 1 bomb alert.
Moving operations were underway.
1 23 year old English tourist,
the family,
23 years old,
was raped at knifepoint
last night on
on the March field.
1 suspect was arrested but it should be known that
she had been raped
since she had isolated herself to relieve herself
behind 1 bush.
The Palace of like many others
historical monuments have been evacuated
following bomb alerts.
2 students today were threatened by 1 man
who had 1 knife and who would have screamed,
Allahu Akbar.
Then the individual was not found
but
there is 1 security operation that is around the
schools
and as a bonus,
1 6 year old boy was killed
of 26 stab wounds.
Family,
it happened in Washington,
D.C.,
That was a bonus.